So yesterday was not a good day for Donald
Trump.
Not only is he reportedly panicking
as he realizes that as unlikely as an impeachment
conviction is he is 67 votes away from being
removed from the presidency.
We have a new report that says he committed
multiple federal crimes crimes, not violations
of his oath of office, which are bad enough,
by the way, and he was raging all day yesterday.
Once again, just tweeting all day, the entire
day spent tweeting and retweeting all sorts
of Ajit trash.
The multi hundred page report from the house
judiciary committee says that Donald Trump
committed criminal bribery as well as wire
fraud.
Now this is a really interesting report because
all along Republicans and Trump have insisted
you can't impeach if there is no crime.
Now, of course that's wrong.
Impeachment is a political process that doesn't
require violating criminal law, but it just
so happens that Donald Trump now is accused
of committing crimes as well.
This set Trump off on another one of these
petulant, childish tirades, including one
tweet with all caps.
Read the transcripts.
Continuing to say the impeachment hoax is
the greatest con job in the history of American
politics.
The fake news media, all cap capital, FNM
and fake news media and their partner, the
Democrat party are working overtime to make
life for the United Republican party and all
it stands for as difficult as possible.
Trump also going on to brag about the stock
market.
We know that he thinks because he has said,
if stocks are doing well, how do you impeach
a president tweeting quote new stock market
high?
I will never get bored of telling you that
and we will never get tired of winning.
Now just as a reminder, here's video of Trump.
Two weeks ago, on a day that stocks fell 400
points on the Dow saying he doesn't watch
the stock market,
but if the stock market goes up or down, I
don't watch the stock rocket.
I watch, uh, jobs.
Jobs are what I watch.
I watch making the proper deal.
We've been taken advantage of in the United
States by China for so many years.
Yeah,
he, he doesn't talk about it on days that
it's down.
I think more accurately we could say.
Then Trump coming completely unglued about
his upcoming 2020 reelection campaign in a
multi tweet explosion saying quote, I look
very much forward to debating whoever the
lucky person is who stumbles across the finish
line in the little watch.
Do nothing.
Democrat debates.
My record is so good on the capital E economy
and all else including debating that perhaps
I would consider more than three debates.
The problem is that the so called commission
on presidential debates is stacked with Trump
haters and never Trumpers.
Three years ago they were forced to publicly
apologize for modulating my microphone in
the first debate against crooked Hillary.
This is the president tweeting folks as president.
The debates are up to me and there are many
options including doing them directly and
avoiding the nasty politics of this very biased
commission.
I will make a decision at an appropriate time,
but in the meantime, the commission on presidential
debates is not authorized to speak for me
or Republicans.
Now we're going to dig more into this debate
stuff on the bonus show today, and I know
that producer Pat has many things that he
wants to say about it.
Trump then continuing all day, I mean it is
all day long re tweeting endless propaganda
videos from Fox news and Rudy Giuliani, the
narrative being it's all a con job.
Everyone's been tricked, they're attacking
him unfairly.
It's all unbelievable.
So don't be tricked.
Trump is raging because he got caught, but
he still might get away with it.
They did it in public crimes in real time.
Some on live television, some on Twitter,
witness tampering, intimidation, all this
different stuff.
And the right is helping Trump turn himself
into a scapegoat or even a martyr.
One of the biggest differences between Nixon's
1970s and Trump now is that Nixon didn't have
the benefit of not only a degree of partisanship
that, listen, people always say, we've never
seen partisanship like this before.
That's true, but there's always been partisanship,
but it is worse that now than it was during
the 1970s.
But also this fact free alternative fact,
post-truth thing, which we will talk about
later today, which makes it so that no matter
what happens, you have a media, uh, apparatus
that will excuse, defend, or counter accuse.
Uh, no matter what it is that Donald Trump
has done.
And unfortunately they will likely get away
with it in terms of impeachment, maybe not,
but they will likely get away with it and
we can't let them get away with it in the
November of 2020 election.
Although I know I'm supposed to always pretend
that everything is great and every, uh, I,
I don't know that Donald Trump is going to
be denied reelection in November of 2020.
I'm scared.
I am going to address this more a little bit
later on this week.